so I'm a huge huge fan of Lord of the
Rings and every time I see this image
part of my brain thinks that this is the
eye of
shon but actually this is the first
image of a black hole and it represents
an extreme case of a data pipeline where
petabytes of data were SED across four
continents to a super computer where
they were processed and synthesized to
this image of a few
kilobytes my name is Alexandra scis my
background is from as physics and
cosmology from where I entered the
fascinating world of data science and
now I'm working as an R developer at
Epsilon in this presentation I'm going
to walk you through some real example
and I'm try to pass to you some handson
experience on how to build effective
efficient and secure data science
workflows using the vast and mature
ecosystem of far and posit connect
augmented by the gamechanging package
targets so we are living in an era where
the size and complexity of data has
grown
exponentially in addition we have a
multivers of different Computing systems
and data Technologies and tapping the
value of data requires careful planning
and execution so that all these
necessary systems and data Technologies
are linked together effectively and
efficiently if you don't pay attention
to this you may end up facing
chaos so contrary if you follow best
practices on the way that you
orchestrate your data science workflows
then you get multiple benefits like you
increase reproducibility and
transparency you have increased your
data quality and data Integrity of
course you have much better streamlined
your processes and all this tend to lead
to much more reliable state a and up
to-date Downstream
applications so let me be more specific
now what's the task we're at abilon and
we have a project with a big Pharma
company and the task is to automate a
process that accesses a secure data Lake
and this secure data L uh contains quite
sensitive data there are jxp data about
clinical trials there are cancer
treatment data and even the Genome of
the patients is in there
so what we want to do is to grab some
views from there some summaries that can
be publicly available and uh unload them
to an external file storage an AWS S3
bucket this is an efficient cloud
storage from
AWS and then copy this data to a
downstream database where we want to do
our pre-computation our
optimizations it's a red sift cluster
that we will use and of course build
Downstream application
with SH that we want to be reliable up
to date
Etc and we will use R and targets as our
squee army knife uh to glue all this
together so let's see the requirements
in more detail we want
transparency and by transparency we mean
that whenever this process runs we want
to produce some kind of a report uh that
other people can inspect what happened
during this pip line we want security
and for security here we have also quite
a bit of a constraint because we are
talking about jxp data in a data Lake uh
whatever action is performed in the data
L should be traced back to a particular
person so you cannot blame the robot uh
here if something goes
wrong we want also automation we want to
run this once per day and of course we
want efficiency and with efficiency we
mean that we have this our genomic data
that can go up to billions of rows and
this process can take
hours so we deployed this pipeline as a
quto document in posit connect and uh
posit connect really served us well in
terms of uh security because I can
control who can see this uh um process
and uh uh I can specify the users there
also um I can securely store my
environmental variables and here from
the UI from posit connect we can easily
store our personal credential so uh now
I have this nice Synergy where I can put
my personal credentials there but
control who can run this process so I
said it that I can run this process only
and all the other people uh just uh can
see a static HTML generated by the
process for automation it's also very
also very easy from the UI you can see
that it is easy to schedule a report to
run once per day and of course uh
reports version it's very easy to
inspect you can easily go back to
history of the
reports so posit connect really served
us well in terms of uh security and
Automation and uh we follow best
practices we write our unit test
integration tests data
validations but something is missing
here and uh what about
efficiency so the next day the pipeline
triggers and uh everything is computed
correctly but do I really want to
recompute everything because for example
if the inputs have not changed then uh I
already know the results from the
previous day so looking close closer to
posit connect at the bottom line it is a
cloud worker and a cloud worker means
that uh it triggers a process it does
some computations and then it writes of
course some data in the file system but
when the cloud worker stops then
finishes the process then everything
from the file system
vanishes so this means that there is no
easy way for me and for posit connect to
remember what happened the previous day
so here we are trapped in a groundhog
day right where you have to leave the
same day over and over again and this
goes even worse for the development
process because even if I do the
slightest change in the pipeline I
should recompute everything and this
turns like the joyful process of
building a data science workflow to a
cfan process where I have to recompute
everything over and over again so let's
see what went wrong here and uh see what
options we have to get out of this
trap um this is a concept from ETL
pipeline it's a very easy concept it's
called directed a cyclic graph so
consider two inputs two tables called
Data one and data two I read this data I
process this data and when we We join
this
data and uh you can see the flow of the
logic from the left of the right and
this is a directed ayli graph
I can go now even further and generalize
this notion where ABCD can be any kind
of steps and uh here in our case b can
be un load some big genomic files to the
S3 bucket I might compute some
correlation and regression in the
database for genes that can take hours
Etc so what I have created here is a
null or nothing scenario and this means
that whatever whenever I trigger this
pipeline Everything is invalidated
Everything is processed
again and what is the desired Behavior
so consider here this G node that it is
like a kind of a logic that I just read
a small file from the file system that
can take
seconds and uh when this file changes
this node is invalidated so what I want
to do is just to recompute the nodes
that are related to this part uh in my
uh workflow and omit the other steps
that can be like big uh computations
that can take
hours so going back to my previous
experience from uh research and data
science what usually we tend to do is
like we introduce some kind of an
abstraction that we call the job or a
chapter or something like that and what
you tend to do is to break this down to
some kind of steps that you load some
data you process some data
and then you save some data and then you
continue on if you want to extend your
project you introduce a new job you load
some data again process data save data
and this goes on and on and you start
creating something like a higher order
graph where you uh do things
manually but still here you have somehow
breaked out from this uh ccan cycle for
development process but still you have
to to do some custom scripting to
declare the sequence of jobs you should
do some custom scripting to skip to skip
steps and you should also do some custom
scripting for example to sh workflow
data so you should be careful all the
saved files for example if you are in a
cloud worker to push them to an external
file
storage that it is
persistent and uh this is just part of a
real pipeline in the wild this is a
small Pipeline and these are the
components of the pipeline how they are
connected together I think you will see
in the next presentation on a bigger
view of this uh and uh do I really want
to take up all this complexity because
uh this um now will I'm prone to errors
and it's much more difficult to
collaborate with other team members this
is the chaos I was talking about so here
is where Target comes into play targets
is an opinionated framework about you
have to Str how to structure your data
science workflows and your data
pipelines and if you follow its uh
conventions and the way that it suggest
you to build your workflows then you get
out of the box many
benefits uh targets will automatically
infer the directed as click graph for
you it will strategically skip Steps
From the pipeline for you
it will also uh like a keep strong
reproducible evidence for
you and uh it has great facilities to
integrate with cloud
storage and of course it has great
facilities for distributed
computing so how targets achieve this
targets introduces a simple abstraction
that it is called the Target and the
target is just a function that outputs
an object and by convention this object
is pushed to your persistent file
storage so let's see a Target scrip in
action in these first three lines we
just set the in so you load targets you
set your options and with tar Source you
can load your custom
functions and this list is where all the
action takes place so here is where I
Define my
targets and uh in this line of code code
T Target uh like uh declares that this
line of code is a Target and then you
got get data the function that outputs
an object the data object so here we
have this Duality get data function
outputs data object and then get
data takes us input to file object that
it is generated by a previous Target and
this goes on and
on and targets will directly infer the
Ed as a click graph for you and uh it
will put in the correct order all these
objects so file now is before data and
they will be computed
correctly also targets has how we call
it metaflow integration and uh by
metaflow integration we mean that
targets will send all these metadata and
intermediate files that have been
computed to a persistent file storage uh
here we use an S3 bucket so you can just
set the
options uh and uh declare your S3 bucket
and now you have uh many benefits some
of them are that you can now scale up to
petabytes for your storage you can just
switch on data Version Control and of
course you have portability and by
portability we mean that uh this
pipeline can you can run this pipeline
in different machines and
developers can share cast results
between them so if have if I have run
the pipeline and have precomputed
something um like my colleague can share
the cast and uh uh Save hours from his
development
process targets has also great
facilities for distributed computing it
uses crew and uh it's very easy you can
just go to the options at you set the
number of workers here we said two
workers for example and targets will
start these two workers and check if uh
worker is available and as soon as it is
available it will send the next Target
there so here let's consider a very
simple case I have a data U some data
and I fit to different models with this
data and uh this can take uh again it's
model feed can take some time and
targets will check uh if a cloud if a
worker is available and it will send
these computations there so they are
computed in parallel and it has also
nice facilities you can also go even
further to more classic distributed
computing like using sound systems
Etc um for deployment now it is also
very easy you just uh set in the quarter
document one line of code Target star
make and this will trigger the pipeline
for you and will do all these nice thing
nice things so you can automate it
easily in posit connect and you can also
easily read uh any like a previous
object that it has been computed and
like uh displayed it in your report for
example here we summarize the data
object that we computed in the pipeline
and now everything is inspectable you
can create your code books you can
create your validation reports and like
a extend your uh report that it is
generated during the
pipeline so uh going back to our case
where we have deployed uh this uh
pipeline in posit connect um by let's
say moving and refactoring and uh
reframing our processes into a Target
project uh like uh brings this uh like a
completes the picture and uh uh with
minimum effort now we have like a case
of Maximum efficiency and
scalability and uh
yeah uh I couldn't resist to not share
this meme from my social media yeah it
is uh uh now that we have uh um uh nice
pipeline it is uh
open source also um written in R this
means that it is extensible also it is
resilient you can integrate with uh any
system that uh you want and uh you can
move on on building your Barb land
perfect
dashboards and uh share this uh with
your organization so that everyone
benefits from this uh uh
process so the next time that you have a
project that it is uh uh some logical
steps a workflow a data
pipeline uh you can just use targets
reframe it into the targets project even
if it is like a mediumsized or small you
will get all these benefits and it will
uh bring you out of the mindset of
creating like ad hog scripts manual
scripts for your grow flows and linking
them
together so uh if you want to uh yeah
please reach out to me on LinkedIn this
is my LinkedIn profile here and uh yeah
use targets thank
you thank you so much alexandros uh so a
quick question um how was the experience
of integrating targets with connect for
the team um it it was a quite nice the
thing is that the the biggest
bottleneck one of one of the things that
you have to solve is that you want to
have to to store this data somehow so
you will need a persistent file storage
or you have a if you have like a
friendly it team you can request for
let's say uh right access in posit
connect in an absolute directory so this
is the the the main thing uh that that
yeah well thank you again alexandras
appreciate
[Applause]
it